Fox News Alert it's been a busy 24 hours
for the president as he tries to make a
deal with Democrats on a border security
and the shutdown but it looks like we're
not getting very far the president
reportedly walking out of a meeting
after he couldn't reach a deal with
Democrats it all started last night as
he made his case to the American people
every day Customs and Border Patrol
agents encounter thousands of illegal
immigrants trying to enter our country
our southern border is a pipeline for
vast quantities of illegal drugs over
the years thousands of Americans have
been brutally killed by those who
illegally entered our country and
thousands more lives will be lost if we
don't act right now this is a
humanitarian crisis a crisis of the
heart and a crisis of the soul the
federal government remains shut down for
one reason and one reason only because
Democrats will not fund border security
today he then had lunch on Capitol Hill
with Republican lawmakers and doubled
down on his demands the Republicans are
unified we want border security we want
safety for our country the only reason
they're against it is because I run the
president and they think they can try
and hurt us going into the presidency
but that's not going to happen and we
don't give up because we're doing we're
doing
but Democrats aren't budging Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer just spoke
after their meeting with Trump earlier
today unfortunately the president just
got up and walked out
he asked speaker Pelosi will you agree
to my wall she said no and he just got
up and said then we have nothing to
discuss and he just walked down I asked
him to open up the government he said
you if I open up the government you
won't do what I want a few minutes later
he sort of slammed the table and when
Leader Pelosi said she didn't agree with
the wall he just walked out and said we
have nothing to discuss now vice
president Penn says he doesn't recall
him raising his voice or slamming his
hand and said the president actually
walked into the room and passed out
candy but unfortunately for Democrats
today the headlines are all about
Schumer and Pelosi 'he's bizarre
rebuttal last night which put the
internet on overdrive with hilarious
memes of the leadership duo one of the
most popular ones was the American
Gothic Pelosi and Schumer another
popular one compares them to your angry
parents finding out you've skipped
school and then there's this one asking
if you need a legal help for an accident
great when you were watching last night
and you saw this these two people there
what was the first thing that went
through you well first I thought they
were trying to sell me a reverse
mortgage but I mean you'd have to go to
the local cemetery to find anything
stiffer I mean they were selected cialis
they could not move and it was in I was
talking to somebody in the greenroom
before it was clear that this had been
written regardless of whatever Trump was
going to say right right so he didn't
give them anything to actually improv or
vamp off of everything he said was
factually correct even and you could
tell even with the fact checking how
forlorn everybody was that they couldn't
find any meat on that bone so instead
you've got lurch and Morticia
I set the Addams Family or is that the
Munsters I always get them confused how
would you know you weren't even born
then anyway Halloween what bothers me
about this is that he brought candy yeah
and this is considered a peace offering
right right
like and then they actually they just
basically rebuffed him after giving him
candy
we were talking oh you don't like Jolly
Ranchers used to like Jolly Ranchers but
there becomes an age when you can't
really eat them anymore this was the
original name for a Brokeback Mountain
take the Jolly Rancher I'll take a Jolly
Rancher but I'm gonna have starbursts I
got the water managers well now if I
give you this from does this mean that
you're gonna agree with everything we
want ya rotten teeth and rock you have a
sweet tooth wow I really do I love
sweets you know but here's the thing
that strikes me and I think Gregg picked
up on this
there was nothing Trump said nothing but
I said that in a good way
well I'm just because you could you're
glad he said nothing but I know you
didn't need to talk about all the
casualties the victims the thing it was
a national address that the network's
got suckered into oh the president's
asked for national time well I guess
he's gonna make news but he makes zero
news I think the president has to make
news I think that's the I think that is
the reason that you get time he stated
the facts well he didn't state the facts
statistics we're pretty fair there's a
national crisis when crossings are in a
twenty-year low watching it Post said
that to her just yesterday and I mean
and then he says oh you know
guess what heroines coming across you
know coming across not illegally in
terms of illegal crossings but coming
through ports of all places this is a
guy who says we have a situation here
where the trade deal is gonna pay for
the war nobody thinks the trade deal is
paying for the war and certainly Mexico
is not paying for the wall so to me it
was like do you want to talk do you want
to counter the port of entry argument I
would like to do the port of entry
because I knew you were gonna bring that
up long I will give you this yes they
seize you know Border Patrol agencies
1,300 pounds of fentanyl at the ports of
entry on the southern border but they
also Steve's 332 pounds of fentanyl
along the southern border but one just
takes a lot of fentanyl Jesse you're
missing the reason why it's
the reason why it's at the port of entry
is because that's often the easier path
once you have barriers so it actually
moves it to port what's the walls yes in
other words it ends up moving it's
coming from suitable ports so you I
don't I think we're in the weeds and I
think this is what Trump does he gets he
gets here all of a sudden like arguing
about well where's this come where's
that nook there is no crisis that's the
point and you're in the minority want
because Washington Post are you calling
there's no crisis people who draw no
crisis know what people dying that's a
no children died get out of the police
are saying and this is the part I liked
about what President Trump had to say he
talked about humanitarian issues but I
thought there was no humanitarian I
don't know if it's a humanitarian crisis
there's a crisis why was it not a crisis
two years ago when Republicans had
control of everything let's get into
Dana here having fun listening to you
all okay so I did think of something
though do you remember when President
Obama gave the prime time address on the
Affordable Care Act like oh that's not
true and that's not gonna work and
that's not the case and it's okay okay
well here's the thing he had enough
numbers to get that passed he paid a
political price for it I think the jury
is still out on that it's not solved all
the problems that they thought it was
going to but that's what happens in
these things I actually think presidents
if they even if they're not going to
make news if the president says I
wouldn't want to address the nation that
the networks indicate was like they
should they should give that because
it's not like he asks all the time
this is his first oval office address
and he chose to do it on immigration
you can choose to think that it was the
speech didn't move the ball you can
choose to think that the speech was
factually incorrect but I do think that
the network's did the right thing in
taking the speech and that he you know
he gets this reputation for being
someone who walks around the White House
fuming all the time and your truck's
Schumer even today says he's pounding
the table and the White House tries to
show no acts
he's quite rational and Briggs baby I
even brought candy look he's so nice
he's a father and he's a grandfather I
think that I don't think that they made
a big dent in moving anything either way
so we're at an impasse but I do think
this is interesting that it's it it's
five billion dollars I'm gonna say just
five billion dollars in the big scheme
of things of the budget on Friday when
the payroll doesn't go out it's more
than five billion dollars so I think
that we've lost a little bit of
perspective here was the Obama address
to the nation the one where you said if
you like your health care you can keep
everybody said it I think that was that
one Emily what did you think about last
night and the Democratic response if you
can call it that mm-hmm
I think so I've been a federal Attorney
you guys know you continue to question
it but atomically and I've been
furloughed and I've handed out furlough
papers and that pales in comparison to
me in seriousness of the day that I was
sitting in charge as a managing director
of 55 federal employees there were
gunshots outside of my window and there
was an active shooter running around
because I was responsible for their
safety of them and me so I don't
understand why Pelosi and Schumer threw
around comments today just today for
example in their response saying the
words tragic and collateral damage
talking about the furlough when that's a
disingenuous comment when our federal
employees are being assaulted and
murdered at the border when our
communities our Midwestern and
low-income and minority communities and
more are being decimated by the drug war
by the drugs poring over the southern
border I encourage you and everyone to
read the 2018 DEA drug threat assessment
report which categorized and was quite
clear about the level of prolific myths
that drugs are flowing across the
borders in both ports of entry and not
and the crippling effect that those
transnational narco cartels have on
literally everything in our system
including our prison population yeah and
including a diplomacy in bureaucracy and
politics and entire entire towns that
are literally in the palms of their
hands so when when the wall is when they
say oh the walls a morality issue or
they talk about this all of these these
government employees at the moment
there's to me greater consequences that
we're dealing with right now that are
being lost in that oversimplified
procedure to the national conversation
how does a wall solve that if it's if
the drugs are coming through legal ports
of entry comes to address that number
one the president hasn't isn't just
talking about a physical barrier but
he's also called for funding for
technology for greater reinforcements
well Democrats a willing judges for
immigration judges supports what the
Democrats said today is if you're
talking about additional funds and and
forces on the border to deal with things
like that Emily will negotiate but let's
not put the wall out there let's not
shut down the government over there so
let's take the same wall that they voted
four or five forty six miles long saying
is the Democrats care more about
Americans missing paychecks that
Americans missing dead family members oh
that's a priority problem all right
forty six miles of Diego